okay we are ready to start with the
second part so we talk about online
convex optimization they might be a
partner on the side says it's on oh no
it wasn't maybe it was okay so now right
we'll talk about full information
problems in the sense that we will have
we there won't be any hidden information
in the past okay it's just what what
comes up in the future and we will take
this so we saw that we could rephrase
that the expressed problem is the
problem of you know picking points from
the simplex probability simplex and this
is like you know drawing mixed
strategies in a game or or again drawing
probability distribution over the
actions that we can do now we can
imagine to have a generic convex set of
sub linear space and this is where we
are gonna pick our our predictions so
our predictions will be points from some
given subset of a linear space and you
can think of them as like in the
simplest case you they could be vector
of coefficients for some prediction
model okay it ain't in a real practical
machine learning problem and and the
game is a similar to to the experts game
in the sense that after we pick our
prediction which again is not a
probability distribution anymore anymore
but it's some more general in the point
in a more general space we will observe
some loss now the main difference here
is that unlike the experts problem when
we could write the losses the linear
loss in terms of the point we pick from
the simplex here we can have a generic
convex loss that is going to score our
predictions our WT predictions okay and
by the on the other hand we will have
access to this convex loss which is the
the full information aspect of the
problem it's just like saying it before
in the in the linear case we could see
all the components of the LOS vector and
in general we could we will have access
and now I will be more precise by
explaining what I mean by access to to
the loss functions the loss function
that we use at each time step and then
after we saw the loss function we can
update our model and so therefore we
will describe a trajectory inside this
convex set that represents our model set
our model class ok so it just you know
to fix your mind you can think of these
losses arising from concrete learning
problems like regression with square
loss or classification with hinge loss
the only requirement is that you the law
should be convex as a function of the of
the W of the prediction of of the
learner okay and again we're going to be
measuring the performance of the
algorithms of its regret and now I took
the liberty of adding this thing here
meaning that I guess like a beauty rate
as a function both of the horizon and of
the element of the set s against which
I'm competing I would like this regard
to be small irrespective to the specific
W from the s so I want to be good
simultaneously against all the elements
all the elements of the model space ok
from which also my strategies are chosen
but something in some cases my regret
that will scale with some properties of
the specific you I'm looking at okay so
but the algorithm will be oblivious to
the you that is competing with so we
will be effectively competing against
all use but the regret itself the bound
itself my scale with the may be the
normal view or something like that okay
so it's it's something you can phrase
many learning problems many sequential
learning problems in this framework okay
so let's see one very simple idea is
okay is the following okay I you know
let's let's look at the all the data I
got so far I have those lost functions I
have them in my hands I can evaluate the
loss functions on any argument so I can
simply you know at time T plus 1 I can
pick the W in my set which performs the
best on the past the sequence of those
functions this called follow-the-leader
okay and however this this approach is
very natural bus is a problem because
you can phrase it as a lack of a
stability problem so look at this very
simple setting now the decision set is a
convex -1 +1 interval on the line and I
have linear losses l1 of W W is a scalar
in this interval and one of that is w
Hoffs and then L T of W is minus W if
deserve even and plus W if still odd
okay why is this is bad for this
specific category this is a bad it's a
bad this sequence of losses for these
are these are losses are convex because
they're linear and this is a convex set
so we are in the right setting now very
simply note that this is an invariant
for any team you have this property here
just by summing up these things see
where you see it immediately so now the
algorithm will will take for instance 40
even will take plus 1 because plus 1
minimizes the loss which is negative
so he wants to take a positive extreme
of the interval in order to minimize
loss but then you have the losses plus W
when T is odd which is the next step he
took plus one as W so we'll have a plus
one is a loss and things will go the
same way in every time step because of
this ultimately thing so the predictor
will keep on flipping between one
extreme extreme um and the other extreme
above the interval and we always
encourage you not loss on all time steps
so right this is not working
we need something and if we said that
this the problem here is the lack of
stability perhaps the right thing to do
is to regularize the problem so I should
or me the task which almost yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's it you can yes yes yes
absolutely that we have a continuous ITI
become excited uh sure but essentially
yeah you you want to we have to go to
the best action in the past so now you
in order to fix this problem you can add
some rigidity you can add what's called
a regularizer in statistics and learning
which is something that prevents you
from you know doing this swinging back
back and forth in in your a decision set
so you you want your you want your next
predictor to minimize the sum of path
losses plus something which is not a
function of the losses but it's just a
function of the it's the function
defined over the model class itself okay
and we'll pick this function in a
specific way which is suited suitable
for our purposes it's going to be a
convex strongly convex regularizer and
I'm gonna be I'm gonna tell you a lot
about this strongly convex business and
why it is it is useful in the notice
that we also have a scale parameter
because we were summing up two things
that
you know apples and oranges so we'll
have some a trade-off parameter beta
which will we'll be able to set up a
tune the two contributions here so this
is an algorithm that was sort of a yeah
it's it's a came up in the context of
online learning was introduced by was at
least phrase it by Sasha left Schwartz
and affinity has run in rattling in
these two papers but we see that there
are lots of connections between this
approach and and previously known
approaches alright so right why strongly
convex s so what is a strongly convex a
regularizer so in general that function
a real valued function defined on a
common subset is a strongly convex with
respect to some norm if essentially it
grows more than linearly in every
direction so this is the the first order
expansion of the function and you want
the function to grow faster than its
linear expansion and by faster means
more than some beta positive beta times
the normal between the point around
which you're expanding and the point on
which you're evaluating your function
okay and it's defining we expect to the
generic norm so related the notion is
that of smoothness a function is smooth
a convex function is smooth with
respected again to some norm if it
doesn't go doesn't grow too fast with
respect to its linear first order first
order linear expansion around any point
in the domain okay and okay if you do it
with respect to the Euclidean norm then
you immediately see strongly convex
means essentially that the eigenvalues
of the actions of the Hessian are lower
bounded on any pointed domain and the
smoothness means that the eigen value of
the action are upper bound and on any
point in the domain okay I don't know I
don't have intuition for different norms
maybe you do okay cool why why is this
thing useful when you want to do
learning okay let's see some examples
first in order to to make it concrete if
we have York Lydia norm this is a square
the clear normal with this 1/2 thing
this is one strongly convex with respect
to itself okay and because you see it's
actually smoothing and strongly convex
and it's motor simultaneously with the
same coefficient because well if you
write it down immediately see it let's
be let's be a little bit more generic
the squared P norm it's P minus 1
strongly convex with respect to the
squared with respect to the P norm and
the entropy in this for P in the simplex
is 1 strongly convex with respect to the
one norm and then you can have power
norms I don't know whether you call them
power norms I like to call them Powerman
arms where we tried to find it again
with respect to symmetric and
positive-definite matrices those are
some early comics with respect to the
normal day different they themselves
define and ok a key concept which was
already mentioned in the yesterday and
when we were talking about primal-dual i
believe is that of convex dual or thank
he'll conjugate of the convex function
this is a function and define it in the
following way all right you see this
definition no so let's see what it means
let's set to make sense out of it so
suppose that you have actually this I
believe this has to be ok let's suppose
we have a convex function on the reals
that as f of 0 is 0 so it goes through
the origin and then you look at this
definition here and now let's suppose
that guy you take your take you want to
maximize this you take here this is a
concave this is linear this is minus
converses concave so you take it so the
Maximizer you take the derivative to
find a Maximizer and suppose that you
can find some w0 such that this is true
so now when you plug this choice back in
here that the gives so that the
Maximizer is given by this expression
and this expression tells you
essentially the
because f of 0 0 then f star of theta is
the error in approximating f 0 with the
first-order expansion around f of w 0
where f of w 0 is the point such that
the derivative of the function at that
point
equals to equal is equal to the argument
of the complex tool is that was that
clear i don't know me but it may be a
picture so you can okay let's say you
have a convex function you can view the
convex signs you have an alternative
representation of the convex function in
terms of the bundle of its tangents okay
so now is it telling you if you want you
have the function here you want to
compute the function dual or the convex
conjugate at some point theta you have
to pick a straight line whose slope is
Theta and have it intersect the the
curve your function and then you look at
the intercept with the with the y-axis
which gives you the value of the
expansion the error at around zero okay
so this distance here is the value of
the complex conjugate at theta where
theta is this slope was that better I
don't know but you can think about it
okay so let's see we give examples in
clear Norma the the complex conjugate of
the complex do all of Euclidean norm is
decreed a norm itself oh that was easy
okay how about P norms okay this is also
easy the convex dual of the squared P
norm is the squared Q norm where the cue
norm is the dual is the dual parameter
of of P meaning meaning that okay this
is also fine how about the entropy
actually this is a negative entropy but
it's fine
so the convex well the entropy is the
level of the expand of the sum of
Exponential's you do your computation
and it turns out to be anything about
the power nodes this is also easy okay
these were positive definite and so
you'll you take that the
the convicts do all of the power norm is
the power norm defined by the inverse of
the matrix okay so you can you can play
with these things you can make
competitions and it's fine as nothing
too complicated so let's see some
properties of these strongly convex
functions so the converse tool it's
amazingly whenever the function you
start with this strongly convex so it's
not only convex but this strongly convex
it's convex dual is everywhere
differentiable and it's also one over
beta smooth where beta is the strongly
convex parameter with respect to the
normal which is the dual norm of the
normal with respect to which the
function was originally strongly convex
okay and the second thing is that you
remember in order to compute the convex
no value added to result you get those
the suburbs you had to solve a
maximization problem now the Maximizer
of that maximization problem that gives
you the convex dual is actually the
gradient of the dual what amazing it's
true you can find it in any book on
convex analysis and this turns out to be
very useful because now ok let's go back
to our follow the regularizer reader
this is our you know this is our
champion for doing online convex
optimization we saw that
follow-the-leader didn't work we are
hoping that by adding regularization we
get something useful you get some nice
bound so okay we're gonna pick this
strongly convex organiser and we now
have we know a lot about these these
beasts so we can hope that something
something transient comes comes out so
the first thing we do is that okay we we
want to get rid of of convexity we want
to transform the original convex when
the during the original problem which
have was with the convex losses we want
to linearize it how we do linearize it
so this is a distant anis regret you
want to bound the sum over t of these
differences with this is your regret
spec to you and the way you do it is
that you just take a Taylor expansion
and because the functions the function
is convex you can drop the negative
second order term and get an upper bound
and now you have these gradients which
are vectors so you can view this as a
linear problem in which your loss
vectors are the gradients okay so do you
didn't lose too much well you know if
you're able to cope with any convex loss
linear losses are convex so what the
hell you didn't lose much of yours
you're still in the convex case I mean
it's a special case it's like okay so
now you want to rephrase your follow the
Reg Arizer leader you want to make it
easier you want to cheat a little bit to
say okay I want to solve it not using
the original convex losses but I want to
solve it by putting the gradients
instead of the convex losses because I'm
looking at linearize that regret so okay
I'm using the generalized losses
directly in the definition of the
algorithm I can do that I know the past
gradients this is this is just you know
I just need the gradient information
this is all I need from past the loss
functions okay now I can look at this
this is again that my follow the
regularizer leader but I have now the
gradients instead of the losses and now
I can just call this thing over here I
can call it minus theta why not
nobody prevents me from doing that now I
have a minus here I can write this or
miniature art max by flipping the signs
so this minus become a plus and this
plus becomes a minus
hey now this although this looks really
like the the thing we had in the
previous slide not by chance it really
looks like the thing we had here ah
so since the function the regularizer
were strongly convex I can write this
thing as a the gradient of the comics to
all of my original regularizer
up evaluated at the sum of the gradients
of past losses why did I do this I mean
what's the I mean this is my nice but
well the real reason for doing that now
I can really have a sweet and short
analysis of this algorithm by
using this sort of formulation okay so
let's see what we get
I get the following thing so I know now
that I can write my the solution of my R
max okay which was my weight okay now I
can write it like this it is this is my
next model my next prediction I can
write it as the gradient of my on the
dual of my regular regularized evaluated
at the sum of the gradients of past
losses okay I can go back and now I can
rewrite my follow the regularized the
reader with linearized the losses in the
following way
I do this prediction I suffer some loss
I compute the gradient and I update my
parameter theta here by adding up the
gradient will remember this theta was
the the sum of negative gradients so I
put the negative gradient in the Sun
okay so you see I have a gradient step
here but then I have a projection step
in which I'm using I'm not changing the
geometry of the problem because I'm not
predicting in the trajectory of the
gradient descent which is this but I'm
predicting in in a by mapping the the
gradient descent into a different space
using this mapping this vector mapping
okay so I'm changing the geometry of the
problem I'm not hoping this is going to
help me in order to get a nice bounce
okay
okay this was a little tough
let's see okay there's a little trick
here so you remember so somehow is that
there's some magic here because you see
this guy is actually taking in account
the fact that I want my next model in
the set s okay so this this thing here
is defined everywhere so the domain of
this of this function is is the entire
inner space I can evaluate on any theta
indeed my gradients are not restricted
in
not at all restricted these gradients
will wonder in the in the linear space
but my prediction will always belong to
the set s because I'm a strong girl girl
my strongest uh Malika mr. Reiser is
defendant that on that domain so this
this operation is also implicitly doing
a projection in the domain I can have an
alternative version which actually makes
this projection explicit and this is the
alternative version of mirror descent
which makes this projection projection
step explicit and further unfortunately
it will be a projection according to
something which is called the Backman
divergence which is a notion of it's not
a distance but is a convex thing
according to which 2k you can project on
a convex set which is induced by your
regularizer
what is the advantage of explicit ating
making explicit the projection step it's
because essentially many times I pick a
regularizer which is defined on on the
entire domain like a norm like a squared
norm
I can pick like the pin or squared P
normalize regular Iser this is the final
an entire D dimensional real space but
then I want to restrict my prediction on
subspace so I have to you know I have to
restrict my regularizer
onto the space and make it infinite
outside of this set s and this makes
things kind of ugly to work with so I
can actually rewrite the enamel or
descent using this alternative
formulation and I will be able to use a
regularizer define it down on an entire
space and then by by means of this
projection to project onto any convex
that I'm interested in okay and this I
can do not with any regular risers but
with many of them at least I need the
regularizer to be differentiable to do
it okay so let's see some examples of
these things so good old online gradient
descent or gradient descent I can run it
in an online fashion okay so I have a
sequence of convex losses I can just run
gradient
of the sequence of Commerce classes so
this corresponds to using the quadratic
Euclidean norm as a regularizer then you
can see that the derivative so that dude
the dual of this as I said before is
again the quadratic a Euclidean norm and
the derivative of that is gonna be W
okay if I take the derivative of that I
get W so basically I'm not doing any
projection I'm just running a gradient
standard gradient descent in the
original space and I'm using that those
things for projection for predictions
and then I can do a new freedom
projection if I want to restrict to a
certain set because this is a good
regularizer so I can write this form of
ourn I'm here at the center and I will
get this this formulation here instead
of the gradient instead of Euclidean um
I can use a P norm and things will be
similar okay I love them a little bit
more complicated update but essentially
similar but now we can change the
geometry of the space by playing with
the regularizer
so for instance I can use an entropic
regularizer and this will confine my
predictions to the simplex and I will
have an update which will have the
exists X this exponential form in which
I basically multiply the exponent of the
negative gradient of the loss okay and
this and then I normalize to project
back in to the simplex so this is called
exponential at gradient and was proposed
by Givaudan and Manfred warm up a few
years ago and it's now sort of recognize
that there's a member of this on line
where the same family for a specific
irregular Iser so what are the
advantages why should I change regular
Liza what is the advantage of play with
the geometry of the space and what does
the choice of the regularizer by me in
terms of regret okay so let's see first
of all let's see I can analyze this
algorithm so this is a little one I'm
going to show you the proof so is one
slide so so this is the Wregget bomb
that you get
so let's see you get the constant term
which is a term that depends on the the
value of the of so you're computing the
regret against some element two of your
comic space and this is the constant
term that depends on the the complexity
you can view this as a complexity for
instance in the case of Euclidean norm
this is going to be the norm the query
the norm of the vector of coefficients
you are measuring your get regret
against the algorithm doesn't know
anything about that so you're
simultaneously good against all of them
but your regret is going to scale with
the norm so this is a complexity measure
and then you have a term here which
scales with T with linearly with T but
luckily you have this term which you can
use in order to get a square root of T
bound as we will see in a moment and
this term will contain the strong
convexity parameter of the regularizer
and the norm of the gradient actually
the dual normal with respect to the
normal with respect which sorry Phi is
strongly convex so this is something
that you know you would like to bound to
get the cost of bound on in order to get
at the end of meaningful regret so so
suppose now that your gradients are
bounded in at least in your comic set
that you're interested in and that the
diameter of your space phrase in this
form you know you can think of these as
norms in most cases that will be norms
so this is sort of it that yeah the
square root of the square root of the
diameter of the space actually the
square root of the square the diameter
if you like because these are squared
norms and this is bounded by D now if I
pick this up appropriately I get this
thing here this is it's reminiscent of
what we saw for the Express case so now
we don't have a logarithmic dependence
on the dimension here we still have a
square root of the rate and but we have
a dependence on these parameters here on
this quantities here which account for
the gradients
the loss and how big is the space in
which I'm playing my game okay and now
you can if you don't like you know
conditional Nick you can think that okay
if your loss if your loss is a Lipschitz
then your gradients will be bounded in
the dual norm so Lipschitz Ness of lost
season is enough to get about here okay
so now you see I have a general bound
which will be okay for all convex
sequence of loss sequence of convex loss
functions for all regularizer strongly
converse organizers for all convex set
sets in which I project given that those
sets have to be bounded because I have
the diameter that appears to be here
that appears in the bound okay I don't
see the time so okay let's see how do i
D analysis the analysis we really
realize of this on the smoothness of the
dwell coefficient so what how do I work
I do the I just write a definition of
smoothness okay which is that so I know
because the fire was at the regularizer
or strongly convex the dual will be
smooth and this is definition now I
recognize that this is the weight and
this is the minus the gradient because
they the sum of the gradients is Theta
so the difference of the data would be
1:1 gradient okay now I can do this is
really really simple so now I can write
this thing over here and now again I
recognize that I pick out the you I will
get the sum of minus Zeta some of the
gradients which is my data parameter and
then I have this guy here now I go to a
convex analysis book and I find out that
there is an equality which called thank
he'll yang inequality which is
completely that nothing to do with
learning with anything like that but
it's just a property of the strongly
convex actually converse the walls so
this this difference is does most debt
with the convex wall
oh cool now once I get here I can use
telescoping it to open up this thing so
these things cancel and I'm left out
with that
so this is just inequality and now I can
again I can look up here and say oh
these two things are the same so I can
put this stuff back here just making
sure that this is W this is minus the
gradient and this is this difference
will be again the gradient because this
difference is the gradient so it get the
norm of the gradient and that this is my
bound then I have to take care of this
guy here but this is just again a little
a little trick a little black magic with
convex and while it is not a big deal so
this gets me the bound because I have
now my regret that so this is the words
my regret somewhere okay this is the
okay this is the right this is the
linearized loss of the player and this
is the linearized loss of the competitor
you okay so I proved my regret bound
which is this one oh this one here okay
this was easy let's see some examples so
okay so post I have a linear prediction
so I have some side information some
instances and I predict with linearly
and then I have sir I paid some convex
loss so for instance regression we
square linear regression with square
loss No maybe so assume that I have some
bound on the derivative of my loss this
is a scalar loss and I have some bound
on the norm of my instances okay maybe
the P norm of my senses for you know for
for some P so now I can round for
instance if I run on line gradient
descent the simple gradient descent
which was used this great potential I
get a bound of this form which we depend
on the diameter of the space according
to Euclid and norm because I'm using
because online gradient ascent uses the
Euclidean potential the squared
Euclidean potential however this term
which depends on the lip and the
magnitude of the derivative and then I
have this other term which depends on
how big are my instances and all
together this is has this kind of form
here okay at most
these are the admission of the space so
now what happens if I run eg so I
changed the geometry of the space what's
happened what about what happens here
well now I'm playing my game in the
simplex and I see here I have a
dependence because I've changed the
geometry I have a logarithmic dependence
on the number of dimensions instead of
having the Euclidean norm of instances I
have the Infinity norm of distances so
together I get a bound of this form here
which holds four elements in the simplex
so and now you see this is very really
reminiscent of experts indeed if losses
are linear and they are their work of
zero one coefficients then I really
recover the experts bound for hedge so
the algorithm is edge and you have the
Express bound for hedge okay so this is
gem utilization of hedge for convex
losses instead of linear losses okay
I mean I linearize the problem but I'm
still looking at the regret the original
regret for convex loss and interesting
enough you can get the same effect the
same logarithmic bound if you pick a
square the P norm instead of the
entropic organiser and then you pick a
certain value for this P which which is
of the order of log of witches of the
very close to one it slightly bigger
than one and you can get exactly the
same bound okay more examples so so what
happens if the loss is really is really
Caesar is more than convex so we these
bounds are tight
if losses are linear we already saw a
bound a lower bound for linear losses
but what if my losses are a positive
curvature everywhere so my loss is a
strongly convex then I can have a faster
rate and one example of application is
really minimizing the SVM objective the
SVM objective for support vector machine
is the sum of the hinge loss plus a
regularizer which is the squared norm of
the linear predictor of my of my support
vector machine coefficients now this is
really a strongly convex function so now
you can rewrite
the SVM objective as the sum of strongly
convex functions and then I can
approximate the SVM objective by running
Orlan grid in the center on a random
sequence of T training examples so I'm
doing stochastic gradient descent
effectively since my losses are strongly
convex I have a faster rate than the
square root of T which I had just for
convex losses and indeed I have a
logarithmic rate so I can approximate
quickly approximated the SVM objective
just by taking the average of the
sequence of models that are generated by
your language a descent when I ran it on
the sequence of training examples so
this logarithmic bounce will hold for
any sequence of strongly convex losses
when I just ran or GD the simple
language a descent by taking advantage
of the fatty losses of function did this
losses are strongly convex I needed to
use a different tuning for ETA because I
have two ETA will be tuned and slice it
in a different way okay so your faster
rates how about how about losses that
are neither convex nor strongly convex
so there's interesting family of losses
that are it's more it's it's a it's a
weaker than strongly convex but slightly
stricter than convex it's called X
concavity which means a negative
function is a concave that we whenever
is strong strongly convex only along the
gradient direction and this is the
formal definition okay so for instance
logistic loss and these kind of losses
which using portfolio analysis are
examples of X pocket losses and all
right so even for X concave losses you
can get a logarithmic regret so you get
a fast rate as you you are getting fast
rate for a strongly convex losses with
online grading descent now you can get
on a fast rate logarithmic rate even for
the larger class of X pocket losses but
then you have to use a different
algorithm which is called online Newton
step and this algorithm is using the
gradient but is the conditioning the
gradient with this in diverse of this
matrix which has to do which will
contain the gradient information the the
sort of a
second order information about the
gradients okay and this unfortunate is
not an instance of a more online mirror
descent you cannot write this online
mirror as online mirror descent but you
can do an analysis using a similar
technique but not quite at the same at
the same proof and then you get a bound
which contains the same gradient bound
at the amateur bound and they have a
logarithmic term instead of the square
root of theta this is for all you in in
your convex set and you can extend it
also this bouncer to convex losses you
want to get a logarithmic bound but okay
I'm gonna skip this in the interest of
time let's say okay this is another
example I like this is a line with
regression so this is a ridge regression
run in the online in an online fish
fashion and this applies to square laws
so in this case you can phrase read
regression in in the online setting as
online we're descent with an adaptive
regularizer
so your regularizer much like in the
online Newton step case will contain
second order information but now I can
really phrase it I can phrase that the
old your algorithm as a specific
instance of allomere the same just with
a regularization that changes over time
the analysis becomes a little bit more
complicated but then I get a regret
bound which has the the advantage of not
being restricted to some convex then I
don't have any diameter information
explicit diameter information here so I
call this Oracle inequality because this
inequality this regret inequality will
hold for any element to you for any
competitor you in the in the Euclidean
space so you see the cumulative loss of
my predictions will be at most
accumulative loss of any set of
coefficients you plus a complexity term
which which is the norm squared norm of
you and then I have a logarithmic term
in time okay and these are the
parameters you can see here so this is
square loss linear prediction with
square loss okay so this is a parameter
less Algren and this scale
three the algorithm doesn't have to know
the scale of the problem it will just be
able to compete against any vector in
the interior space okay some more now
you can there are more sophisticated
scale-free algorithms for general convex
losses these are more recent results so
this is another example which is again
an instance of a line mirror descent
with the adaptive regularization so here
you get another oracle inequality which
holds for any convex loss function and
you here you see since you're competing
against your you don't have any any
specific loss you don't have a strongly
convex sauce you don't have a nice
concave loss you just have a convex loss
you will have a square root of T degree
rate but here again you have an Oracle
inequality so you're competing against
any any predictor you form from the
entire space and you penalize as before
you penalize with this base regularizer
here which is contained which can be any
strongly convex revised which is
contained in your adaptive regularizer
so you have a bezier Iser and an
inductive part which depends on the data
so this is really nice because somehow
the algorithm is learning the is
learning the the difficulty of the
problem in terms of the curvature of the
losses is encountering on the way and is
adapting the regularization in terms of
information that is contained in the
losses observed so far okay this is a I
think is a really nice and exciting kind
of there are not many very many examples
of these adaptive realizations but they
buy you this very nice parameterless and
scale-free algorithms ok oh oh you're
almost done
ok there are other ways to achieve
regularization for instance instead of
using a strongly convex organiser you
may use a stochastic a regularizer
which is like a random vector picked
according to some distribution and this
is the way your follow the riser leader
looks
whenever you
a stochastic a regularizer instead of a
strongly convex analyzer then this is
called in the linear case this is called
follow the perturb it leader is an
algorithm that due to Kauai and Van
Paula but you can phrase it also for
general convex losses and for some
choices of the distribution of the
perturbation this regularizer becomes
equivalent to a linear descent
meaning that the disk these things will
be the same I provided the sequence of
losses is the same ok so this is another
possibility
what else have I got here whoa this is
shifting Anglet ok so one thing the
people always complain about is that
fine you give me this beautiful online
setting in which you don't have any
distributional assumption on the
sequence of data on the last sequence
but then you are competing against the
best
the single best guidance near model
class if your sequence of if your data
sequence is really non stationary
there's not going to be any single guy
who's going to perform best on that
sequence you know you may have a
sequence of complete or sequence of
elements from them from your mother
class that are good for your that will
fit well your data sequence so now the
question is can you compete against an
arbitrary sequence you're getting close
to the competitive we are we are sort of
entering the the area of competitive
analysis and it's not really true but in
the in spirit yes because we want to
compete against the sequence of models
not on a single fixed model so we want
to compete a bit against the best
strategy which is picking a different
model at every time step in order to fit
the data so clearly you can fit whatever
you like if you can pick a different
model at each time step so the only
thing to make sense here is that you
introduce in your regret a penalty term
which is the shifting model cost so is
the distance travelled by your model
sequence a long time so you have a
trajectory of models you are competing
at least against this trajectory of
model and your regret will scale with
the fit of this trajectory of models and
with the the distance travel bye-bye
right you know when when you when you do
this when you go along this trajectory
and then you will laugh again at the
diameter of the of the space s and some
other terms that are not less
interesting this is another very
interesting way of phrasing and the last
thing I would like to mention here
probably yes because I'm already a 1
minutes over time but we started a
little late so this is another way of
tracking a moving target so now let's
say suppose that this is called strongly
adaptive regret suppose the following ok
I'm competing against a single model but
now I want to compete against the
specific sub-interval in my in my
sequence of steps so I would like to be
simultaneously good against all models
in my class on any sub interval of my
horizon ok so I'm picking some interval
of consecutive steps and I'm saying okay
when I sum my losses on this interval of
consecutive steps I want to be I want
this to be small with respect to the sum
of the losses of my competitor on the
same set of steps and of course the the
regret here should scale with the length
of this interval so with s minus R
indeed you can do that so you can you
can sort of modify online gradient
descent to get a regret bound which will
be simultaneously good on against any
competitor in a bounded convex set and
against any sub interval of consecutive
steps in your in your in your history ok
so in retrospect you go back and you can
and this will be an invariant of your
regret for all you all I of this form in
the way you get is through a reduction
there is a amazingly there is a black
box reduction you take any online
learning algorithm for online convex
optimization and you can just run a
logarithmic number of instances of this
all green and do something on top of it
in and that this will get you
efficiently with just a logarithmic cost
in time in in the great because in time
make a logarithmic cost in time in the
regret will get you bound strongly
adaptive regret bound okay so this is a
quite quite nice
and so I finish with just mentioning
briefly the fact that you can play
bandits also in this more general setup
of convex losses and the idea here is
very natural is instead of observing the
gradient of the loss of the entire loss
function you just observe the value of
the point the lost data of the point you
played this is the only feedback
information you get but you are still
facing the same regret okay and there is
a bunch of amazing results from for
linear losses and we have tight bounds
in the linear case for strongly convex
the smooth losses we have this kind of
bounds there for general convex but
losses this was this long standing open
problem and only recently well only
recently people could get the square
root T bandit rate for any convex loss
and this is the currently the best
dependence on the dimension which was
gotten already only a few months well a
few weeks ago and Sebastian will tell
you about that in in a man's in less
than a month in the next workshop okay
this is all I wanted to say thanks a lot
for your attention
the launcher took its toll yes one
question no there is some normalization
there's some normalization yeah there
will be a dependence but it's although
the dependence by me mild the
logarithmic but there would be the
dependence yes which one of them so yeah
strongly adaptive so the the losses and
the distance they seem like apples and
oranges are there's like normalizing
terms out there
no it's it's similar to what we had here
you see here's the same thing you have
them well
you can't introduce parameter in your
regular risers and then but essentially
it's it's a really like a model fitting
model cost yeah you yes yeah because I
was thinking you know I could take the
lost functions and multiplied by a
million and right there
oh here okay is there a square maybe it
was a long time ago I forgot this is an
old slide I'm not sure there is this
okay okay so there is a this brings me
today only to the half slide I skipped
so you can't think you can make things
to scale invariant so for instance so
one thing it you you complicate
completely the fact that you know if I
if I see if I have like a problem in
which I will like this and I scaling my
instances you know now the scale of the
problem will change but you typically I
have a you know a bound on the diameter
of my mother space and then I have a
hillock here a bound on the diameter of
the sphere where all distance leave now
if I change the geometry of one I I mean
I there's no I should change also the
geometry of the other set because if I'm
scaling my instances now my models
should scale accordingly and so there
are ways of rephrasing like hopes on a
noodle step in such a way that you have
like a single single constraint which
tells you that sort of the inner product
between models and instances should be
bound
but you don't have any individual bounds
on on the two of them
so now if you rescale everything
according to any linear transformation
so your scale instance is according to a
linear transformation the algorithm on
change its predictions because
everything is this is a scattering okay
so I hope this addresses but only with
respect to with respect to the original
coordinates set
so you're scaling you're killing on
coordinates this is like any linear
transformation of the data you can
rotate it then
what these kind of convex optimization
projects are there they are these are
that's also good it is coming from a
distribution okay there is a this is
ongoing work I mean I don't think
there's a lot known in in there there
are a few few papers that's addressed
this problem but I don't know much about
it personally it's it's an active
learner research this is all I can say
at the moment I cannot there are a few
results